okay now I've got just enough space down
here because thankfully for us
linear graphs are really quite simple
this is going to be different when we
move into a m5 we're going to look at
all kinds of curvy graphs they're a lot
more complicated so they have to be
bigger but for Part C I think we can
mostly get away with a reasonably
compact looking graph now think for a
second about the axes you're going to
draw I've got my vertical axis here
don't draw this but normally we draw a
set of axes like this yeah
however there are huge parts of this
Cartesian plane that are quite
irrelevant for example which axis is
which which one's the vertical one which
is the horizontal one okay so I know
which ones look like which but am I
gonna say cost and no root eyes which
one should go on which axis okay I'll
put cost up here and I'll put number of
x over here other way around so the in
depends on the X okay now have a look
over here have a look over here see this
region over here on the left hand side
on the let's make you on this left hand
side number of ties is on the left of
zero what numbers do we put over here we
put negative numbers don't we yeah it's
like I'm this is a tie destroying
factory okay well that doesn't make
sense in this situation okay so you have
to do more than just blindly draw this
equation to draw the points you've got
interpret what's going on sometimes
negative values make sense in this case
they do not so therefore I don't need
this part over here what about down here
what's going on here negative costs now
I guess you'd say [ __ ] cross this sort
of like profit but in this case we're
not really worrying about that we just
want to work out how much does this
thing you know costing us how much money
we're putting in so actually these are
the only parts of the graph that makes
sense okay
so that's a bit small I'm gonna make
this bigger same thing so I'm raising
this just to say think about which axes
are important if for example the
vertical
for something like say temperature
that's an easy example where actually
the negative axis is meaningful and
sometimes important depending on where
you live I guess ok so think about it
this is cost over here and number of
ties over here alright let's put the
information that we know onto here
where are we gonna go on the y-axis
where are we going to intersect with it
at what value I should take cost axis
1,200 now 1,200 a big number where
should I put it on this axis I'm
actually gonna put it about halfway
here's why look at the other values that
you've got right I'm gonna get bigger
and bigger and bigger values on our
table we're going to go all there to
1950 that's not quite twice as higher
but it's a lot higher than this so I
need some room to move if that makes it
so I'm not putting that number right at
the top I'm gonna have to have some
markings in here so I have a reasonable
scale 1,200 up to 1950 what do you think
is a good number to be at the top mm is
a nice round number let's do that if I
put 2,000 at the top and there's 1200
okay I want to make sure that these
distances are somewhat consistent I
should actually probe with that a little
bit lower because you can see the
distance from 2000 to 1200 is what's
that gap what's the size of that girl
it's 800 so it should be less than this
amount ducky because that should be 1200
is that okay okay so far so good now
because these are all in a straight line
I could put all of these dots on but all
I really need is the last thought okay
because I didn't put this over here
let's go 50 100 150 200 250 if I put the
last one on sorry let me rewind up a bit
so we've got our beginning point in our
end point but if I have a look and you
guys have a grid on your book which is
um advantageous to you if I put on the
rest of the markings at 50 100 200 and
150 sorry and 200 they
being all on the correct coordinates if
I've done my scale properly and that's a
lot quicker then actually do it each one
individually and trying to measure them
out when that's not really necessary
okay so I'm gonna put some final numbers
on here this one goes down to 250 and
this is 1115 and that's my graph okay
right so now we can finish out by
actually using this model to answer a
question so we've just constructed all
of this together what they want us to
try and find out is how many times can
we produce if this is our daily cost now
just before we answer this question why
would this be a question that we might
actually want to ask in what kind of
situation might we know our daily costs
but not know how many times we've
produced the bills so if you've got if
you're going back and you're checking
through I'm auditing some company and I
can see all of their bills and how much
they've spent on things I can backtrack
to work out how many times they should
have produced and all that kind of thing
that would be helpful I can think of
another one I might be the business
owner and I might have looked at my
budget and I can say I can afford one
thousand four hundred ten dollars per
day based on the loans that I've got
based on all my other costs this is how
much I can spend on this particular
Factory so how many tires can I make and
not go over the expenditure I'm supposed
to spend okay so I'm trying to do some
planning here and that's what I use this
model for now you'll be able to do this
but I can't because my graph is too
small and inaccurate I'm gonna have to
find one thousand four hundred and ten
on which axis which exercises related do
yep the vertical axis so you want to
find where one thousand four hundred and
ten years in here on my graph there'd be
sort of around here I'd say you can
actually measure that you can use your
grid squares to do so from this vertical
value what are we going to do with that
how will we use the graph yeah very good
so I'm gonna get another color it's hide
yeah
are you looking for sure Sophie its mr.
Clemens just as well so because you go
see mr. Clements in his office
downstairs do you know which one his is
when you go to that door on that type
just come around the stairs when you go
down the stairs turn left and then go to
the first door and he's a pretty coaster
there I could give you more instructions
but you probably know remember thanks
okay sorry I think George wasn't you who
said or someone yep take this value and
I'd encourage you to actually draw this
across so if you have another color
that'd be really helpful measure a cross
until you hit the graph and from the
graph you then are going to measure
downwards okay
now I've done my very best I'm
predicting it's between 550 and 100 when
you measure what can you see what can
you see around 80 around 60 around there
now I'm guessing those numbers I'm
guessing those numbers on the basis of
the fact that we actually have this
model so if we didn't have a graph or if
we didn't have an accurate graph how
would we actually do this what's a way
to check our answer I've got the
equation as well which is more precise
right so I'm gonna try this out I've got
just enough space in this corner over
here
1410 where would I substitute that into
the equation I've been given um yeah
it's a cost isn't it the daily cost is
so I'm gonna pop it up to here so I'm
gonna go one four one zero equals 3 and
plus 1200 you see that I don't know what
any is that's what I'm trying to find
out okay so I need to do a teeny bit of
rearrangement here so you can see if I
subtract what should I subtract
1,200 from both sides I get this you can
see how getting closer to making in the
subject and the only thing I need left
to do is divide which if my mental
arithmetic checks out should be what we
get okay so if you drew a really good
graph then this is where you will find
your graph reads down to and this is
called does anyone remember what this
process is called it starts with an I so
word we don't use very frequently so
that depends on its the graph if the
graph is the issue okay
please write this down next to where you
just answered Part D this process is
called interpolation now people don't
talk about interpolation very much we
usually talk about the opposite
interpolation which is extrapolation
does anyone know what extrapolation is
okay good so here's our graph right if I
wanted to say predict the cost of
manufacturing 500 tires okay I have to
make a prediction but it's not on my
graph it's outside that's extra exterior
it's outside my graph but this value is
inside my graph so that's why it's
interpolation okay